recently CNN asked with all the good
news why aren't people smiling it's like
the local skunk wondering why everything
around him stinks there cluelessness
results from a complete denial of how
Donald Trump works fueled by a
confirmation bias that seeks only to
prove their negative point take North
Korea just months ago it was nuclear war
Trump's fury the president is warning
he'll respond to North Korea's taunts
with a fire and power that the world has
never seen will the war of words
escalate into an actual nuclear war what
he actually said is if there's gonna be
more threats not an attack but more
threats from North Korea we're gonna see
in effect a nuclear war President of the
United States today threatened nuclear
war that did not age well nor should it
we can't let the press forget it either
especially as Trump heads to an historic
meeting with an unpredictable man with a
strange air cut but enough about Rodman
Rocketman months ago he was dr. evil and
now he's at the table it reminds me of a
sitcom from the 90s
[Music]
so we'll see what happens
[Music]
we'll see what happens let's see what
happens
we'll see what happens so we'll see what
happens
we'll see what happens Oh God
now before you say Kim wins by inclusion
isn't that how diplomacy works you know
meet with the guy talk to him it's funny
dialogue used to be the left
safe word we're always being told we
need a national conversation about stuff
so here's an international conversation
yet the same dopes who condemn Trump's
fire and fury now chide the opposite
maybe if Trump says he's dialoguing with
Kim CNN can avoid another crying jag the
good news we've gone from fretting over
war to debating the hotel bill how could
the press miss this well they hate the
guy Trump that is there so married to
safe predictable politicians whose main
risks involved choosing the red tie for
the fundraiser Trump runs circles around
them because in his world he had to I
said it before Kim may be a dictator but
Trump's a developer from Queens I'm not
sure what's scarier all right I guess I
should break the news here that I am
going to Singapore okay are you wearing
that no no no I don't have my
credentials yet how are you gonna do on
the plane I'm gonna do great I'm gonna
do great I'm just you know Gork is going
so work is going I think I should be
able to go right whoever is flying next
to you on any flight I mean why
shouldn't one of us be able to go
I mean waters world should definitely go
yeah you with Diamond and silk intro you
know it was so ridiculous
you know the 70s show right yeah but the
thing is now that's the world we're
living in yeah I mean Dennis Rodman yeah
come on man this is ridiculous now now
you're approaching the point where you
say this isn't but this is absurdity
this is like like some something
somebody dreamed up a plane you'd say
that play is doesn't work nobody's gonna
believe that that jumped the shark
long time ago but yo but to your point
this is something that hasn't happened
before and maybe that's why it's
happening Dana they took a salesman from
Queens liked the process he always
looked at like a process when you're you
buying a house or renovating a property
could you say that that's how he's
looking at this maybe but I also think
that one of the reasons it's happening
as well is that the the Kim family it
was kept track of them being the
ultimate one he they got the nuclear
weapon yeah so now now they feel like
they're equals they feel like they have
an ability to come to the table and
actually negotiate I don't the sticking
point about denuclearization what does
it really mean and how will it all work
I'm I would say cautiously optimistic
yeah it's not necessarily a cynic or a
skeptic on it I do hope that it works
but I also know that we're dealing with
the North Koreans I thought it was just
dopes like me who were skeptical know
everybody is Oh we'll see what happens
Gregg is like defending the president as
just a salesman from Queens he's just a
guy from Queens yeah now the Democrats
argument would be oh wait a second don't
we usually have people who have mastered
foreign affairs and diplomacy involved
and they had this they decided believe
me they were previous offers from the
Kim family the grandfather father and
now him for meetings but everybody said
no because we're not giving you that oh
then he said that was dopey and old
school that's what this is do you know
what trumpets he's like The Blair Witch
Project after that movie came out all
other movies changed thank you horrible
camerawork yes horrible I was terrified
yeah runners for the wand misguided
believe they should be doing the same
thing say the same thing because the man
has nukes now he didn't have nukes
before make sure that
oh so here's the thing people get upset
they think Oh Rob man it's like a
sideshow he's obviously not gonna have
any place in the negotiations this is
gonna be president ron with kim
jeong-hoon if kim jeong-hoon feels more
comfortable like no one's out to kill
him with his friend for life Dennis
Rodman they're fine give him is security
blanket okay let him have him there
it'll be fine
who cares that's the bottom line like if
ultimately the goal gets achieved and
they accomplish something and they're
able to denuclearize would anybody
really care whether Dennis Rodman was in
the country at the time or not I'm about
the results and getting moving on target
and getting to the finish line there so
if that's some kind of peculiar thing
that makes them feel more comfortable
that isn't some kind of like you know
assassination plot on him or something
and he's like okay this is I'm gonna be
safe my buddy he's been there six times
to North Korea yeah how many people
could say that you remember when the
left sent James Taylor over to Europe
for diplomacy and they thought that was
brilliant says Rodman and he gets beat
up for that I mean I don't see what the
difference is my timber lease points
exactly correct he's met little rocket
man more than any other American yeah
all in the face of the earth they've
done karaoke together they've gone
skiing together they've played ping-pong
together basketball listen to the things
he said about Dennis Rodman
he says he's like a little kid who
doesn't want war he thinks Americans are
gonna try to take over the country so he
wants to nuke up and he feels like
that's his only defense he wants to help
his culture improve and he loves America
they said when he went over there he
played the soundtrack of Dallas and he's
like Greg four hours straight he plays
those theme songs
he likes the Joey is insane
[Laughter]
but to your point about a real estate
he's like a motivated buyer right he
really wants his country to succeed and
he really wants he wants money and Trump
wants to help this guy so he brings him
to this 5-star luxury resort where it's
like a $35 $3500 tasting menu peacocks
roaming around it's got this like
east-meets-west deal it's a six thousand
dollar Presidential Suite he's saying
listen capitalism could be good if you
do the right thing yeah yeah
now he's read art of the deal which was
the last time it is now it's it's it's
the it's an old sales tacit tactic that
you have the client thinking they have
something to lose that they already have
so they've gotten this far and they
don't you know they're the teenager and
I've said this before Giuliani
you know was talking about North Korea
and he says that he's got North Korea on
his knees these are the things you
shouldn't be saying no no Giuliani stop
say that in your private dinner party
yes not on television all you wanted to
feel like a win-win even if it might not
be right I agree you know the real
person we should be talking about going
John Bolton is he going yes Oh travels
in first class
[Laughter]
it's not personal
anyway I think he's the one that scares
Kim jong-un's
right right I agree and and the reason
is because as Jesse was alluding to the
threat if someone's gonna take him out
and what happened to Qaddafi when we
made the Lib that what's the problem
Bolton said that right it was a problem
but the out the the contingent on part
of that is a wait a second I think
Bolton was a big opponent of the Iran
deal you know ideally if we had the best
possible outcome from what happens you
know what it would be the North Korean
deal along the lines of the Iran deal
when both ins an opponent there what you
mean where you can self inspect your own
nuke the North Koreans to build right
now go on with that bogus argument the
for so you only have a
inspections every billion dollars in
cash you want to do Trump administration
certified the deal so I'm just saying
you know we I think that what happens
here by the way is we just go back and
say oh yeah the Korean War is over we're
gonna try to be friends this is the
start of the process I think the
president said much the same the one
thing though is that he's breaking news
today about I was an AP President Obama
fudging about the Iran yes so apparently
the Obama administration let the
Iranians skirt all of these financial
sanctions to give him access to like
billions of dollars of hard American
currency that no one knew that they had
to get a lawsuit from I believe Judicial
Watch to find that out and then the AP
reported it so the Obama administration
to make it easier for the Iranians the
largest state sponsor of terror to get
cash behind the world's back and that's
not a scandal it's not a saying on this
one you knew that the whole idea was to
give them the money that we had frozen
there was their money in the first place
and then second money one Detroiter it
was their money integrate them into the
global economic strata why why we're
that's front of us just your reaction
because people because they did go
waters to react oh I don't want people
to go hyperbolic over something because
it's something to get upset about
Danish well I'm just gonna say it's not
only that it was the Obama
administration actually went to a couple
of American banks and tried to ask them
to do this it's not money laundering but
it kind of feels like that which is
basically say make this money right look
and the banks refused wait so you're
saying bankers have higher ethical
standards now concerned that they would
be penalized because of it okay Kim Burt
Lee last word how do you think the media
is gonna cover this sensational they're
gonna try and make some jokes about it
because of Dennis Rodman like they have
but nevertheless the I think the outcome
of it is gonna speak for itself you know
in terms of being results-oriented he's
gonna do what he does isn't he's able to
work a deal sees
will to now go and meet with Kim jong-un
when no one else was able to get him to
the table think about that exactly you
know what I found in the green room I
found this book in the green room it's
by its newt gingrich's book oh that's my
copy no it's to Steve Doocy a great guy
a great guy who's been a friend in the
morning and Steve left it in there oh
yeah some friends know I got a free book
Steve never leave a book in the green
room